merci jean pierre alors après le centre
et l'ile-de-france je vous parle est un
petit peu de cette normandie cette
normandie une région parait-il qui est
connu dans le monde comme deuxième
région après la californie
c'est une région qui a une identité
évidemment très forte une situation
unique placé aux portes de la région
capitale avec une façade maritime
exceptionnelle donc des atouts tout à
fait extraordinaire et malgré ça le
parti socialiste qui gère la haute et la
basse normandie jusqu'au 13 décembre
prochain malgré souvent un affichage
considérant que cette région à une
gestion comptable acceptable maîtrisé et
bien l'exemple de la normandie quand
nathalie parlaient de la façon dont les
régions socialistes ont géré nos
territoires est un exemple assez triste
le constat est assez sévère puisque au
delà des chiffres qui sur le plan
national nous amène un des taux de
chômage catastrophique à une situation
pour nos jeunes dramatique des
agriculteurs malmené puisque en
normandie
nous avons un poids de l'agriculture
très fort et bien en normandie
nous avons des indicateurs qui sont
encore plus mauvais qu'ailleurs plus
mauvais que la moyenne nationale
et on retrouve tous les ingrédients de
la gestion socialiste
un budget de fonctionnement qui a
explosé qui a plus que doublé en 10 ans
une fiscalité équivalente doublement de
la fiscalité entre 2004 et 2012
bien évidemment en parallèle un budget
d'investissement totalement berne
nous sommes même pour une région qui
demain fera l'équivalent de la bretagne
et du pays de la loire nous sommes
aujourd'hui sur un an région comparables
sur un dépassement de plus de 150
millions d'euros
en matière de budget de fonctionnement
est de moins 170 millions d'euros en
investissement
nous aurons donc bien sûr à rééquilibrer
les choses une région qui n'investit pas
qui n'innove pas est une région qui
régresse pour nous demain la normandie
comme toutes les régions de france
doivent donner une autre image de la
politique régionale
tu as dit roger la compétence régionale
à un élément essentiel la compétence
régionale c'est l'appui au développement
économique
ce développement économique tous les
français l'attendent
parce que nous avons fait notre
leitmotiv de campagne avec hervé morin
sur l'idée que la meilleure réponse à
l'emploi c'est l'accompagnement de la
croissance et donc le soutien au
développement économique
le soutien nos entreprises que ce soit
les petits les grands les agriculteurs
les pêcheurs les commerçants les
artisans
nous avons besoin de leur dire et de
leur montrer que nous sommes capables
d'investir dans les infrastructures dans
l'accompagnement de leur développement
dans l'apprentissage de faire en sorte
que nos jeunes soient plutôt investi
dans la formation professionnelle en
matière d'apprentissage que dans des
contrats aidés dans des collectivités ou
leur avenir est totalement fermée voilà
ce que nous nous voulons pour nos
régions demain et après guillaume qui a
parlé de la renaissance
nous avons fait le thème de la campagne
en normandie sur une normandie
conquérante une normandie qui envie de
rayonner une normandie qui a envie
d'être connue dans le monde
au delà de son patrimoine et de son
histoire mais aussi pour des entreprises
innovantes nous sommes nombreux je crois
dans cette salle à faire campagne sur le
terrain aujourd'hui nous rencontrons des
acteurs économiques absolument
formidable nous rencontrons des artisans
des commerçants des agriculteurs des
gens du monde du sport de la culture qui
chacun à leur niveau réalise des projets
tout à fait intéressant il demande
qu'une chose parfois qu'on leur laisse
un peu tranquille sur un certain nombre
d'éléments administratif mais surtout
que nous leur donnions des moyens
efficaces
pour les accompagner dans leurs projets
de développement nous n'avons pas besoin
de nous occuper de leur stratégie
économique nous avons simplement besoin
de leur montrer que nous sommes là pour
porter des projets d'infrastructures un
accompagnement une identité
en gros les aider à avancer merci à vous
merci